[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it
dear Kahlan and Hank it's a comedy
podcast where two brothers and
occasional special guests because John's
really sick right now answer your
question can be devious advice a minion
while the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon how are you doing I'm
doing great I just googled AFC wimbledon
news just before this so hot off the
presses ok as there is some news I don't
know it might not be that new I don't
know they're playing the season is
active so things are how are you doing
oh I'm good I'm good I've gotten a bunch
of stuff done today I'm a little bit sad
that my brother is super sick yeah he is
I think feeling a little bit better but
yeah it was not up for a potting or
making a video yeah he was like started
working on this video this week and he
was like nope oh so he's not good do you
get a punishment if you skip a video and
you're saying no it's being sick if it
should be a punish right I mean it's
been so long since we've done the
punishments I feel really bad about them
and we procrastinate them now yeah and
it's like what up with with
nerdfighteria be like so can we just
like abolish the punishments and people
are like no so not sure what we're gonna
do I'll probably have people vote yeah
and hopefully they'll be nice cuz now
you can vote right on the YouTube video
right which is awesome which is awesome
yeah so people for people who don't know
Caitlin Hofmeister is the producer of
scishow I make solve makes a scishow
work and manages all the scishow team
and also hosts scishow sometimes and it
is I just recorded a couple more
episodes I kind of backed off of it for
a while it is still active it's called
you're doing just fine
and I touched two successful people
about their failures good so Hank if you
ever wanna talk boy I was going through
an old hard drive recently and I found a
lot of failures just like wow there's a
whole there's a whole directory called
side projects and there was like 20
things in there all of them are not
existed
there's a reason they're still in that
ya folder and I still I still have
active side projects folders and I have
I have a task list on my google base
yeah it's like I never click on it and
it's big ideas and what I do with big
ideas is I let them sit there for a year
and then I come back and I'm like oh so
glad I didn't do that that was such a
bad idea that's such a bad big idea what
makes them big like that they're gonna
be hard - yeah like that they're not
something that I can do in a week you
know yeah there are things that I'd have
to hire somebody for or they'd be like
you know dead egg like a lot like like a
book like the project right yeah so that
one you are doing I am doing one of them
but there's another I've got other big
idea both on the list yeah I still want
to write my book about animal sex Oh
totally it's really high on my list
yeah things that I would like to get
done in my life yeah just let's talk
about all biology through the lens of
the weird ways we make the next
generation which is you know what
biology is all about it's about
continuing this stuff forever remarkably
well yeah I know for the last few
billion years done real great at that
yeah
life just kept working yeah it hasn't
stopped yet and I like life I was
thinking about this when we were
recording a scishow yesterday that life
will find a way but it also doesn't give
a crap about individuals you know it's
like if you are weakening the system of
this species you're out yeah yeah that's
how it works that's how but the other
thing is that uh that the it feels very
strange to for it all to be related to
each other which it is unquestionably
like we've looked and seen how similar
you know and like understood that you
know the direct relationships between us
and various organisms and how the
branches of the tree work and also that
kind of the like the way that we die
isn't the same way as like a sink like a
single-celled organism dies but the way
that it replicates is in the same way
like you can say and then my child is a
different
organism than me but when a
single-celled organism replicates like
which one was the original one right is
that kind of the city so like yeah so if
one goes on to continue living and the
other one dies and then a replica like
which one was it and in that way
single-celled organisms are all the same
single-celled organism so then are they
yeah they don't died they're still there
yeah that one that first cell yeah he's
still there I don't know come here my BS
science people yeah for that one cuz if
not we're doing a scishow on that hey
Caitlin do you have a short poem for us
I do have a short poem it's by Marianne
Hoberman and it's called brother because
I'm your fake brother and I love poems
that you can read out loud that sound
like children's books so this one is
that I had a little brother and I
brought him to my mother and I said I
want another little brother for a change
but she said don't be a bother so I took
him to my father and I said this little
bother of a brothers very strange but he
said one little brother is exactly like
another and every little brother
misbehaves a bit he said so I took this
little so I took the little bother from
my mother and my father and I put the
little bother of a brother back to bed
No
so if that ever happened to you did John
try to trade you in in one way or
another nice that was great I also like
I love children's books obviously and
it's remarkable when you hit a good one
in you oh man this is so much fun I want
to read this like every night yeah for
weeks which is good because you have to
yeah cause otherwise you're reading the
same book every night for weeks and
you're not enjoying all right so we have
questions from our listeners Kaitlyn
yeah I'm excited to give you
yours in pieces of paper I do which is a
thing still it's loud
crinkle it for the for the people wait
you can't
it's my paper those great is there this
first question Oh what the heck is this
the wrong oh my god I think I have the
wrong one open our first question comes
from Nathan who asks dear green boys I'm
in a large vinegar soaked vegetable by
which I assume Nathan means a pickle
I've been and I have a group of friends
and life was going great but now all of
them have either began dating each other
or other people sadly such is not the
case with your homeboy Nathan much to my
aunt's chagrin my my people and what
seems to be a poorly executed plan to
keep me around but also to be with their
significant others indefinitely have
decided to invite me on a single teenage
chap on every quadruple date they have
gone on for three months I once drove
two of them home from a coffee shop
after watching the group conduct an
unruly amount of PDA at each other and
then on the way home they kept doing oh
man Nathan I'm sorry my life is suddenly
turned into a sitcom and not one that I
can press pause on and watch later would
having a girlfriend make my situation
less Seinfeld asked please answer soon
I'm scared for my sanity ah it's from
Nathan Nathan I've I have been the
person who had a really tight-knit group
of friends and I was like but also my
girlfriend is now part of this we're
gonna be obnoxious about it
yeah I've been that person I've been
I've been Nathan's friend yeah I've also
been Nathan I think yeah but I can't
also come at that from the other
direction and let me tell you Nathan
it's pretty obnoxious like well he's the
way I did it and my friends were like oh
my god yeah I get it you and sherry
you're gonna be in love forever last
three months or was it I mean me and
sherry lasted for a week or two oh nice
but yeah so it was it was easier it was
easier for my friend sent for Nathan
yeah I was it was very exciting for
those weeks is
Nathan's aunt trying to date him no I
would like this like a game of Thrones
scenario once Nathan to be in a row
every time I was just in Subang that
there's a broad story here that anything
is alluding to very quietly which I like
it's like like you know that there's a
whole back story with the aunt that yeah
really is trying to get him hooked up
with somebody but he's not gonna talk
too much about that but just give you a
little hint gotcha like somebody wants
to date him yeah he's not into it
because he's a single teenage [ __ ] well
is does somebody want to date him
somebody that his aunt knows maybe yeah
or she just like pinches his cheeks and
she's like where's your girlfriend later
and he's like god I've had enough of
this it's hard enough to be Nathan in
this world where all my friends are
sucking face in my car yeah I actionable
advice when you're giving people all
right don't let them both right in the
back seat a I'm just your uber driver
like you back in the back of my Pontiac
ya know yeah definitely what yeah this
is a great point who's sitting in the
passenger seat no one well somebody yes
yeah that is not a laughs Ben I'm just
your your your PDA chauffeur I'm just
your like person who's driving around
the room in which you're hooking up it
totally okay and that's too close it's
like people think it's fine because
you're going somewhere but it's not
you're in a very small room together
there's that third person is it okay for
us to be in like a 12 square foot room
with the two of you and Nathan and
you're hooking up yeah I think this is a
general piece of advice that I'm getting
to my former self
like if it's me and my girlfriend and
like one or maybe even multiple other
people like we are in a friend setting
doing friend things we're not doing
boyfriend-girlfriend girlfriend thing
hanging out having a good time
but it's not like a time for public
affection display like and I like I
understand you're young maybe you're at
least I have it's a place that you yeah
alone maybe you don't have that and but
like yeah it it's not inclusive no of
Nathan to be like come along and we're
gonna stare at each other in the eyes
with our eyes open while we can yeah
we'll just be around yeah Nathan you
don't have to get a girlfriend to
satisfy your friends no or your aunt or
your aunt but I do think I do think that
your your you are in a and a vinegar
soaked vegetable there because you can't
really like tell your friends hey can we
be friends still or is this really just
one thing in the world that matters to
you right now yeah you could you could
ask that maybe don't phrase it quite
like that it maybe you don't phrase yeah
my dog puked in the back seat of my car
on one of the back seats so I don't let
anybody sit there anymore hey if you
want to just like be subtle about it
yeah this is a budget or does sound like
a big bag that you're carrying around to
keep that I had to put this bag in my
car I'm delivering it for my mom
tomorrow yeah to the dry cleaners it's
just pickles perfect bag of pickles just
two pack of pickles I'm bring to the dry
cleaners yeah because my mom's a pickle
salesperson this one's from Morgan and
they say dear brothers green and Caitlyn
when is the appropriate time to start
getting into Christmas season most
importantly listening to Christmas music
my mom thinks it's on Thanksgiving
specifically as soon as you see Santa
and Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade hi
I'm a firm believer in November first
being the start of the Christmas season
mostly because that is about as late as
I can possibly hold off
and this debate greetings from the
upside down demo Morgan damn Morgan
Morgan so you're right I also can't help
myself I know it's like yeah like octo
like October ended yep you really miss
Twinkie music I was taken down the
Halloween decorations and I put my son
to bed and I was like that's that's it
yeah it's done time you're getting a
Christmas carol every night until
January like and maybe into January yeah
yeah that's you gotta get your Christmas
tree late so that you can hold a knife
and toe so you can really stretch it out
on yeah you know Christmas trees in
Montana I'm very impressed with their
like they're just like chillin out
hanging in your house if you keep it
especially keep it a little cool in your
house which is probably the
environmental way to do things anyway
yeah Jill just last yeah I like water
and I threw my Christmas tree away last
year it dropped like eight needles like
what US are you alive should I point you
so yeah I mean like I used to be on the
exact opposite side of this debate where
I was like it is not Christmas time
until it is like December 20th
oh wow like a crazy person ya know like
well that's the thing is like I live in
Montana now where it's no it's snowing
like yeah it's like Christmas and I need
to be like celebrating the joy of it
being raised just a dark cold time right
have to be about friendship and giving
thoughtfulness candy yeah where do you
come down I love Thanksgiving but I have
no problem like Christmas yeah and also
since you're in the upside down Morgan I
feel like that takes place like very
early November and there's Christmas
lights
so to communicate with the upside down
are you talking about stranger things
oh yeah there are yeah I'm just trying
to find like text-based evidence for
Morgan being right
and ultimately the current cultural
touchstone for everything is stranger
things so yeah I'm stranger things
there's Christmas lights it's October
it's spooky but there's still Christmas
ah yes so you can celebrate Christmas
yeah just put up some creepy Christmas
lights hanging from the wall will buyers
might need to contact me so good I
haven't watched the finish the second
season yet I'm like an episode three
Catherine like we watched the end of the
third episode she was like I don't know
she definitely wasn't gonna watch
another one that night yeah but yeah I
have this I have a general problem with
my wife where she likes to consume high
quality content very slowly let's just
watch another episode of Qi or the Great
British Bake Off and not finish stranger
things we could do what episode a day
I'll be fine it is really satisfying to
do it that way I did that with the first
season of stranger things yeah because I
was like going to my friend's house and
watching it but it's so hard I watched
the show season in two days
oh man
so do we did we get any good actionable
advice just you can celebrate crisp
here's here's headphones maybe oh yes
this is a great point yeah you don't
have to involve other people in your
Christmas celebrations necessarily you
can be a hundred percent there in your
own brain yeah and you can and also like
you can display it where a Christmas
sweater people aren't gonna think you're
infringing upon their rights but maybe I
think so I was in like the day after
Halloween I was in a retail store and
they were playing Christmas carols and I
do feel like that's a little bit
approaching the line take up a whole
space yeah yeah yeah that's like--that's
I mean it is retail they want you to be
in the Christmas they would be like
remember Christmas is coming up yeah
don't you need to buy socks for that
person it's not just other people sauce
your feet are cold other people's socks
is a weird
what you do when you buy someone socks
yeah because like I currently own your
socks these are yours but I haven't
given them to you yes in general yeah I
have other people's stuff until until
like the Christmas time happens and then
other people have their stuff huh
who owns Christmas presents and the like
in the in the moment between when you
buy them and wrap like when they're
under it with the money tree whose are
they then are they the person whose name
is on them or the person who bought them
I would argue the person whose name is
on them but at that point you like that
happens at midnight on Christmas that's
why you can't open it until Chris yes
that makes sense because it's like this
gray area of property law just like it
was like 11:59 people that somebody was
like nope this is mine I've changed the
managin like they go to court and like
Judge Judy have to determine whether or
not this bird like the the mixer yes
Jeff or Jeremy's
[Laughter]
I don't know I think judge judy would
say that it was the gift errs until
until mid oh and then it's the gift II
this next question comes from sim who
asks zir Hank and Caitlin I love with my
boyfriend now and it's great however
he's turning 25 this December and I kind
of want to make him a homemade gift but
the apartment is 42 meters squared how
do you surprise loved ones in small
apartments pandas and abstracts SIV how
many how big is 42 meters squared 42
meters squared I don't know I've no idea
I'm a little studio apartment that I had
before it's 450 square feet yeah thank
you google it's a little studio
apartment yeah so small yeah um well
homemade doesn't necessarily mean you
made it at home that's true so it could
be a coffee shop made coffee shop made
library made mm-hmm you could go to go
to your local I don't know we have
places like that like we
like the sack where you could go back
start Center yeah and you could store it
there so you just come to Missoula Yazoo
town Community Arts or whatever it's
called
yeah to town arts community center
probably since it's Zach yeah she was
gonna be mad at us yes yeah so stuff
like that probably you could take a
class like a screen printing class or
something maybe yeah and then you could
be learning a skill as well you could
also make a small thing what are all the
wood chips doing under there
why are there somebody wood chips in the
beds if I get I was thinking that sip
was going to make their boyfriend a
present
while he was gone and then no have to
hide it you know yeah like you know it's
like a working like working space on
which Bing okay yeah and I got what do
you let you have left off see if it's
like what is the thing you're me yeah
because this is a this is hugely
important maybe sips boyfriend listen to
the pod and yeah but I like the idea of
making a fort and Cal Chrisman raft fort
do not under the craft fort in the crap
oh god yes yes yes yes yes you have to
build a craft fort yeah oh not only you
I challenge everyone who is making
something for their Christmas person
this is Christmas to build a craft yes
whether or not they're gonna find it I
do think it's great to have a craft for
yeah that's probably how the North Pole
is invented yeah it was originally mr.
Claus Santa just wanted to make
something for mrs. Claus but their house
was so small that he built a craft yeah
and in a prowler just getting bigger
to pay I assumed well yeah I think
they're Union right Santa seems like a
nice guy I think yes yes okay well I'm
gonna ever have we answered a question
that all right did I just ask that
question yeah okay your turn let me ask
you a question from Catherine mm-hmm
dear Hank and Caitlin I work for a
catering company and an waitstaff for a
large number of corporate events school
as is the nature of these events I've
seen a lot of guest speakers and
speeches given I feel very lucky to get
to see these speakers as they're often
important people working on projects
like Mars 1 and space exploration or are
important leaders on the global stage
like Nicola Sturgeon the First Minister
of Scotland I always feel very lucky to
get to see these speakers and I always
want to applaud after their speeches
however I'm not sure if I'm allowed to I
mean I'm just the waitress not someone
the speeches are for so do i clap for
them or not
please help I'm very confused and
conflicted about clapping or not not an
abundance of Katherine okay first of all
the First Minister of Scotland is
something that got me hooked up because
I was like did I say his name no you
said corrected Nicola Sturgeon a woman
no Nicola and so I was just like I don't
hold on a second this is the First
Minister Scotland ever had that person
must be or is it like a ranking it's a
thing okay so the first minister is the
later scholar net okay
like first clean except it's the leader
of the Scottish government instead of
the leader of the clarinets yeah okay so
Nicola Sturgeon is a sturgeon
well they spelled it wrong oh that
wasn't your fault okay Nicola Sturgeon
yeah not surgeon yeah all right so we've
got both of those things fixed okay now
I don't like so obviously you do what
everybody else is doing
oh it all the other all your other
colleagues like this yeah I'd be like
everybody look over it my my colleague
Leslie and see what Leslie's doing that
was not a very same other Kate Merida
yeah one Scottish name Nicola yeah good
point
excellent point yeah I've got a long
list look over to see what Alastair is
doing great and if Alastair is clapping
than you clap yeah first waiter to lead
yes clapping excellent or not yeah whose
name is probably Craig probably yeah so
yeah but I think I I if it was if I was
the person creating the precedent like
if it was me and everyone was gonna look
to me what we should do I would clap I
would - I also I want to have got a bone
to pick with Kathryn because she says
I'm just the way just not someone the
speeches are for yeah I think the person
giving the speech would love it if you
just left and it's also definitely
talking to you right and I guess this is
why I think you should clap yeah I
should clapping because like it's
respectful but also because it's a
recognition that you are not you are you
are not mechanism by which things appear
and disappear you are a person yeah and
you're listening yeah yeah and I think
that it's really cool that like you have
like this is a perk of your job
totally yeah and like like you should
appreciate it and show people that you
were appreciating it and pause in your
duties if you're not currently holding a
hot cup of coffee
yeah and don't burn yourself don't worry
your yeah don't just flaming cups of
coffee together yeah I think I agree and
I think you're probably not at the
clapping point you're probably not like
pouring water on some like for someone
like you're probably just like step to
the side yeah frankerz I don't know how
it works yeah but it does seem cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah and maybe other people
are wanting to clap too but they don't
know if they should mm-hmm maybe
Kathryn's the Craig Wright that they're
looking to and she doesn't even know
brain you can establish the precedent
you see on us and you put your own arm
behind your back
like you're a good no you can't clap
that way yeah yeah yeah just positive
pause in your duties and applaud Nicola
Sturgeon the First Minister of Scotland
yeah yeah I must do me I'm assuming
you're Scottish which I don't know if I
should have done I just because Nicola
Sturgeon was there and I'm sure Nicola
Sturgeon goes to other places probably I
did that whole thing when I assumed you
were Scottish for a long time but
there's no actual indication that that's
the case I apologize this next question
comes from John who asks dear Caitlin
and Hank and Caitlin sorry I just want
to throw away a few bags of trash in the
already full dumpster at my apartment
complex Oh have we all been here mm-hmm
as it was halfway back to my apartment I
heard a bag of trash fall to the ground
did I just litter or am I in the clear
they didn't bother to turn around to see
it was one of my bags but it had begun
it has begun to plague my mind any
dubious advice is appreciated
I won't mow your lawn John it's Johnny
cuz it's spelled like long yeah it
sounds like John yeah you're not you
didn't turn around you very
intentionally yeah appear to have not
turned around yeah for a specific reason
which is the Indians widening your mind
and now it's plaguing your mind
I had a plaguing my mind situation
yesterday there so I went to the coffee
shop to get coffee with Catherine mhm
and on the way there there was like a
minivan pulled up on the sidewalk with
its hazards on and I was like that's
weird and on the way back they were
still there and this person there was a
person sitting in the driver's seat the
whole time and I was like are they okay
and so we walked home and then I like
was sitting in the house taking care and
I was like I have to go check and see if
that person yeah and I finally like went
and I like walked over at the phone
having a conversation I was like you
just pulled up on the sidewalk that's
super weird like on this like on the
sidewalk
to park yeah there's like you've just
pulled around there's like neighborhood
streets that have parking on them yeah
they were they were there for like an
hour
oh I don't know yeah yeah I I was
thinking maybe there was car trouble and
they were like caught like an hour and I
like walked by and I like tried to make
eye contact and she would not make eye
contact with me so I was like you will
clearly do not want me yeah good good
for you for going to check though yeah
maybe she called someone and it was
taking him alone didn't like it there
maybe maybe yeah but she was still like
yeah it looked to me like she was just
having a conversation
yeah like she was like she didn't want
to drive and also not strictly legal so
yes this was plaguing your mind because
you littered yes this is a problem that
like everyone who has ever lived in an
apartment complex knows about like they
don't have enough dumpsters yes
especially right before a trash day why
not yeah yes more dumpsters cost more
money yeah yeah but yes so bigger
dumpster cost more and more dumpsters
cost more this is a thing I know because
we have a dumpster here at the office
very little it's so cute it's tiny I
love so don't throw away more stuff
because we pay less because it's low
yeah I love I love that it's little like
look at us saving the earth as we're
like shoving stuff just a holding stuff
in the garage yeah waiting for it to get
empty but yeah this is it this is a
common problem and at our old a place
because we shared the dumpster the tiny
dumpster with a lot of different people
that like somebody would fill it up with
like bookshelves or something one week
and it does feel like well I guess we're
just gonna put the garbage bags by the
dumpster and then you feel bad because
that's not because I can tell you as a
as a business owner that like the the if
you keep doing that like the if the bags
aren't in the dumpster the company will
get mad at you and they will call you
and be like you need to get into their
dumpster because right we're supposed to
drive that truck up yeah and do the
thing with the truck and that's it we're
not we're not here to pick stuff up off
the ground yeah not trash like not
literate Patrol yeah anyway soup
interesting things that I know about
that I'm so glad that I've learned there
it's like if you ever think to yourself
boy I want to run a business remember
that you're gonna be getting calls from
the dumpster company yeah and you'll
like intuition we get in other dumpsters
yeah you have a conversation with the
stuff away that will be your life you
know it's not bad telling you guys to be
more green and recycling more we do a
good job that recycle yeah we do so so
John you should recycle more yeah and
also if your trash doesn't fit and then
you should call the trash committee be
like my landlord won't get another
dumpster and I know that he needs one so
let's work together yes I love it yeah
so John you littered but somebody will
clean it up but your conscience will be
dirty for the rest of your yes oh yeah
it's all over
do you want to hear from Fannie yeah hit
me with Fanny's question Fannie says hi
I'm watching my favorite TV show in
Sweden called vem vet messed and this
guy is wearing a pizza John shirt I
needed you guys to know yes he is it
looks like a game show
there there are five lights and two of
them are off so I don't know if that's
good or bad I hope they're running down
yeah maybe he's only got three lives
like left I really hope that this pizza
John I mean what a bold choice we're on
it
we're in pizza John on a game show
nobody's gonna not know that happened
yeah that's awesome it looks great you
guys good question now on to my
unrelated questions well Pizza related
is a pizza a sandwich if you fold it
there's bread on two sides Hank I know
you've got this figured out my name is
weird in your country fanny
that is true correct on that last part
so Caitlyn do you know about my new
policy about not having opinions on
stuff ah no I don't have an opinion on
whether that's a pizza sandwich or not I
do oh yeah yeah cuz it's a hurry Toa
sandwich no I'm told that pizza are you
aware
of the controversy or wading into right
but this is like their like it started
with the hot dog question yeah hot dogs
not a sandwich legally way there's a law
well it's because it's like there's some
sort of like sandwich tax they're like
no sandwich
tax yeah I think so maybe I made that up
that was their sandwich tax in America
America like is the corndog a sandwich
oh there's bread on both sides its bread
on all the side right it's completely
surrounded by bread yeah and it's on a
stick I think in general sandwiches
can't be on a stick but this is the
thing they're just trying to suck you
into a conversation
oh and having having opinions and
arguments and disagreements with people
about things okay really
maybe we should just not care if a pizza
folded to half as a sandwich
Henry rice and I were debating if pizza
was a pyre li ER today was it a pie
party and people brought pizza and we
thought is the pie party yeah I did he
assured me there would be more though
yeah yeah cuz they call a pizza pie but
it's not really a pie can be whatever
you want it to be yeah I think that like
it definitely becomes a sandwich if you
take two slices of pizza and put them on
each other because then it's open at
both ends otherwise it's sort of more
like a cheesy saucy taco you know what I
just realized which that sounds awesome
but this person is from Sweden uh-huh
where they have open-faced sandwiches
yeah so pizza is totally a sandwich a
piece is already a sandwich it's just a
hot open-faced sandwich with just cheese
and sauce yeah okay marinara boom next
you know it's like an open-faced
sandwich I'm into it because like often
times I'm like there's too much bread
happening yeah there's too much bread
going on and again this is not an
opinion that I have for all people I'm
not saying everybody should only
open-faced sandwiches this is just a
thing that I believe for myself I often
think to myself that's just
my mouth is full of bread right now and
I was I didn't sign up for bread I'm
here for all that stuff in the middle
gotcha all that Oreo goo Oreo sandwich
an Oreo would be a sandwich they call
them sandwich cookies I think they do
yeah all right
this question comes from Brian who asks
dear Hank and Caitlin when scientists
talk about the age of the universe ie
about 14 billion years old are they
using the year as defined by one
rotation of the earth around the Sun to
me this seems rather confusing as the
earth has only been around for less than
half of the calculated a to the universe
and years usually different on other
planets what's up Brian is greater than
Ryan Brian I mean it says you Brian wait
it has more letters it does have that
extra letter yeah
we don't have any other ways to do it
right yeah it's funny like what would
you what would you say the you know the
universe has been around for like like
18,000 rotations of the Milky Way now
like I don't know what that means right
I have no idea if that's even close to
the probably way not enough yeah and
also the Milky Way wasn't around when
the universe started so like there's
nothing to go by except what we know
yeah and it's something like talking
about a small apartment earlier we were
like meters we think and feet usually
let's look at this up I feel like it
makes sense to talk about years as
egocentric as that is to like help right
Adam it well that's one of the things is
like most of our definitions of things
are arbitrary to start with totally so
like a foot it's just something we
picked a meter is something we picked a
kilogram and something we picked but a
year is at least a thing like its we
were here and then now I was here again
yeah and you know in terms of around the
Sun yeah I'm like we can measure that
and we know that and and that amount of
time is not exactly a number of days
which is what causes all the problem
with leap years and extra leap ears and
seconds yeah in seconds so the yeah
the it's not perfect but it's the thing
that we have and it is sort of like
compared with our other units of
measurement at least it's based on
something yeah yeah and something that
relates to like individual
because you know how old you are in
Reyes yeah yeah and we have some
experience with what a year is yeah I
don't have any experience with what a
year with is that allows me to conceive
of what 14 billion of them would be
though
no me neither
but what would be cool
Brian can you just have that no like
beautiful I don't know like 15 seconds
and then like like it's gonna be 14
billion seconds yeah and then you can
just jump in okay what you were gonna
say but what would be cool Brian is if
you made a poster or something visual
that I could hang in my wall mmm that
showed me how old the universe is in
differs in earth years in Pluto years
because Pluto as long as we've known
about Pluto it still it's not completed
a Pluto year Wow trying to finish a year
Oh nothing's gonna stop me you can't
stop me I'm Pluto you can't stop me
because you can't get here yeah too far
away yeah and you can also do like lunar
orbits around that you could also do
like galaxy orbits or which is not
something I ever even thought about
before that's awesome yeah yeah yeah
like I don't know if the galaxy orbits
something inside of its super cluster
there's got to be some kind of central
point of gravity in the super cluster
but but it definitely revolves yeah or
rotates right so it's like the earth
goes around the center of the galaxy
wants every lots and lots and lots yes
what is that called I don't know what
that's called
that's my fake that's my go to fake
measurement that's good heck takers are
excellent all right we don't have a ton
of time left so this podcast is brought
to you by HEC takers yes taker
are so big more long or or yeah or yeah
unfathomable unfathomable this podcast
is brought to you by moving rooms for
three people that you should not make
out in correct Oh
moving rooms that you should not make
out in no don't make out in them because
there's a bunch of pickles on the back
seat anyway
yes podcast also brought to you by the
Kraft fort the Kraft fort it takes up a
two meters squared of your forty meters
squared apartment and you are in there
doing something and it's gonna be it's
gonna be so good
this podcast is brought to you by the
holiday music that can start whenever it
was it's that you could be you could be
Mariah carrying in your ears all year
long if you yeah to all I want for
Christmas is for it to be Christmas all
the time and if I guess this finally
brought to you by our actual sponsor our
actual sponsor which it helps that
Caitlyn is here today yeah producer of
many videos is story blocks story blocks
is a company that provides stock images
stock video audio and of just tons of it
and it there's yearly subscriptions so
we have so scishow what what
subscription do you guys have beside
yeah mostly use video blocks on scishow
because we have people talking so we
don't need the audio and so we use the
videos yep so we use video box at
scishow so the way that story box works
is that there are those three things and
they're each yearly subscriptions but if
you sign up now through story box comm
slash dear Hank and John you get all
three of them for the price of just one
of them for them it is so it's 149
dollars a year I like this because you
know how much it's gonna like you get it
and you have it for a year you can try
it out you always have that resource
because you're not like a hundred
percent sure when you're gonna be using
it yeah
yeah it kind of comes yeah like the need
comes and goes and they have hundreds of
thousands of video an audio and an image
files and
I use it for vlogbrothers we use it for
scishow Katelyn do you use it for others
because I know you do things sort of
yeah so what a cool thing about story
blocks is that story block slash images
is you can get graphics so I will make
video I make I make advertising videos
for nonprofit sometimes like the Zac
what we talked about and so instead of
me having to make a lower third from
scratch to interviews people introduce
people in the bio because you're like
okay like I'm doing this I'm doing this
like pro bono work exactly I don't want
to spend a bunch of money on it and I
also don't spend a bunch of time on yeah
and so is that like the lower third is
like a like a pre-prepped after-effects
[ __ ] yeah that you can just like drop in
yes your video behind it yeah yeah yeah
flex equals type type though yeah stuff
in there exactly yeah
nice so the so story blocks also so it
has like membership content so stuff
that you get for free and it's hundreds
of thousands of files but there's also
the marketplace so the marketplace is
like people put their stuff on story
blocks and you can buy it from those
people directly and those people get
paid for the things that they made that
you buy through story blocks and I think
that's that a hundred percent of the
sales revenue goes directly to the
artists when you do that so this it's a
great way like so you will run run
across when you're using story blocks
files that aren't like part of your
membership but those files have been
uploaded by artists who are you know
supporting their their life with their
work and and so you have to pay so you
have to pay extra for those yeah but
it's sometimes like four dollars yeah
and then there's like all of these you
know and sometimes they're like 4k video
files and sometimes they're like yeah
they're just
it makes content creation much easier I
know a lot of people so Dania makes it
for for their YouTube videos and in a
world where you know creating high
quality content is going to be more
important for you know whether you're
doing production in a small town like we
do for local businesses or nonprofits or
whether you're doing your own content
making your own stuff having something
that's you know it's like basically a
little bit more than the cost of Netflix
yeah for you to make your you know to
take your work to the next level which
we've been using it for a long time now
I feel like as long as I've been here so
at least five years yeah yeah we like it
yeah it's good we feel very lucky that
story of boxes helping out this podcast
so you want to check them out we also
feel like this story box exists at all
because it makes our jobs easier it's
started box.com slash dear Hank and John
if you want to look into it sign up try
it out for a year and get the triple
bundle images video and audio for the
price of just of one of those for $150 a
year and and yeah thank you thanks for
checking that out cool all right stuff
let's do uh no question this one comes
from Madden who asks dear Hank and
Caitlin what is nil John always talks
about it when talking about AFC
Wimbledon and I don't understand I'm a
lizard madam what are you a little
lizard I guess that understands what
explains why you don't understand what
nil is a thing like I am The Walrus
probably sure is like Madden a game well
Madden is a game okay but it's not
spelled like Madison's name and it's
about football oh oh so you don't know
about man in the game Madden sorry I'm
like you should know about new if you
know about football
no okay I know nothing about football
clearly yeah so I wanted to know where
nil comes from yeah did you look it up I
did so it just means nothing it means I
can tell you what the AFC Wimbledon
scores I know why you hear it so often
Charlton vs AFC Wimbledon was one nil
but AFC Wimbledon beat Lincoln City one
nil oh so they won and lost yeah okay
well you already got to the AFC
Wimbledon is so yeah a couple weeks ago
okay
so the adults yeah situation is that it
just means nothing but I looked it up
and nil it's like from the Latin which
is also where like nihilism comes from
literally nothing yeah yeah I'm into
nothing like annihilate yeah also to
make a camping yeah yep
no it means nothing so that was just
just a quick one for people who are
confused by nil and I don't know why
I'll try to figure out why football
scores in particular talk about nil like
nil nil draw but like nobody knows it's
just something people started doing
maybe because it's one syllable
maybe it's like especially if you're
talking about you being the loser
maybe it's like one now yeah seems a
little more hopeful than one nothing
one zero yeah I'm probably just to save
a syllable off yeah it's probably it's a
British thing they don't like they don't
like syllables they'll get rid of them
at every opportunity even if they're in
the word so this one's from Caroline and
she says dear Hank and Caitlin how long
does a person or persons have to be dead
for it to be considered archaeology
instead of grave robbing does the
civilization have to be fairly old or is
there like an Indiana Jones code of
conduct
sweetly careless yeah so did you look
this one up to you oh well it's actually
something I knew Oh awesome okay so it
does not matter how old the grave is
okay
it matters your intent okay going into
the grave and this is sort of a
controversial thing that's interesting
so even if it's like a Pharaoh's grave
right if you're going in there to let
melt down the gold and sell it or like
even even sell the stuff on the market
your grave a grave robber yeah but like
where do you draw that line because like
early on this is a kind of like kind of
weirdly what we would do we'd go to
other countries we'd like explore these
tombs we'd take stuff out of the tombs
and then we'd bring them back and put
them in museums and Europe and so there
there is like sort of now we're like oh
like we wouldn't do it that way yeah and
that was kind of grave-robbing it was
like a cultural extraction that we did
because we were like well we're Europe
so we're the ones who are interesting
and you know we only know one could
appreciate this stuff like we can
because you know we really understand
things yeah and yeah so it it turns out
that like there is a fuzzy and dangerous
yeah there's a fuzzy and and a dangerous
distinction between those two things
and so really it it comes down to the
like your intent is to bring your
findings to more people and to be public
about it and to be approved by
universities and museums and the
government of the place you are then
it's archeology and not grave-robbing
and if you do not have those sanctions
no matter how old the grave is you are
just a thief you are a weird thief
stealing from people who have been dead
for a long time but more than that you
are stealing from the culture that's
there now and and also just sort of like
from human knowledge which is the worst
yeah totally do you so how could you
make a case for it being archaeology
with a very recently buried person if it
doesn't matter the age well I don't know
that you could yes so you couldn't call
it archaeology but you could call it
science if you wanted to pick somebody
up and say like somebody who died a
hundred years ago and be like well we're
curious how many people died of arsenic
poisoning this community and you might
want to do some science and be like no
there was this like wave of deaths and
we're not sure why and maybe you had
something to do with this thing that
we're trying to figure out then you
would be doing science and it wouldn't
be grave-robbing okay but you wouldn't
be taking stuff out of the ground and
that's an interesting question if you
can like like in a thousand years
people might exhume like graveyards in
the u.s. to be like what did people wear
what well they wouldn't know like what
were their wristwatches like yeah what
was their jewelry like because you
couldn't find anything besides like
clothes wouldn't be their body's way
they're not like they're not like
mummies we don't mummified yeah in the
ground here
but yeah recent recent archeology there
there is I think some some lines
somewhere where archaeology starts and I
asked Blake Blake is our colleague who
is into archaeology and also super
Indiana Jones if you're like I mean he
looks like literally since I've been
working with Blake for like almost seven
years now he's every day he looks more
like Indiana Jones like I expect him to
come in with one of those hats and in
his office so I don't know he's more and
more tan yeah he only gets more buff I'm
like what are you doing when do you you
have two kids and like a very hard job
do you have time to exercise I don't
understand at all all right
oh we are so we are so over time we have
to get the news of marginality Wilden
okay
maybe what some may have seen more than
news Oh God okay AFC Wimbledon is
playing for the checkatrade trophy okay
right now oh wow uh I don't know what
that means
I don't either is it it's probably my
guess is from what I know which is
limited that there are these like side
tournaments that teams play that don't
matter to the official standings
Lexie's glory but yeah just glory that's
awesome so they're playing in the
checkatrade yes that is that like a like
a brand or is that a place I'm assuming
it's a brand where you trade checks
check check a trade checkatrade is where
reputation matters
oh it's how you get tradesmen so you
like do you like it's like Angie's List
that's where you find you find people to
to help you whatever reputation so you
get a check
meaning you you check recommended
yeah so in future news I'm gonna come up
with a cool name for a competition okay
and then they AFC Wimbledon will get a
trophy for it for glory right and they
don't even have to really win no it'll
be like the AFC Wimbledon Caitlyn's
trophy for AFC Wimbledon news trophy
okay so that's our how are they are they
have they played a game are they doing
okay uh I got distracted by checkatrade
yeah I don't know when a game the stats
I have come up from October oh they're
playing a game on Saturday during
they're playing a game on Saturday
versus the Bristol Rovers Oh Bristol
Rovers what a great name for a sports
team yeah unfortunately way better than
AFC Wimbledon and I think that their
most recent game was against
Peterborough which they tied 2-2 which
is good that they scored two goals yeah
and Peterborough played Bristol Rovers
this weekend and beat them four to one
oh I feel alright well maybe we'll do
these balloons chances are good and the
goal the goals in on AFC Wimbledon for
that Peterborough game were scored by
Lyle Taylor the Messi for Montserrat
woohoo and Cody McDonald who I've never
heard from before and that that well
Taylor goal was scored well I'll scald a
scored in the first minute so that's
good and then we went down to on and
then Cody came back and saved it in the
45th minute to make it a tie so that's
that's what I know in Mars news NASA is
preparing to land its 2020 rover on Mars
and so they're testing up the parachute
system so if you want to watch a
parachute open at supersonic speeds but
slow down a lot so that you can actually
watch it happen with a high-speed camera
there was a test called the advanced
supersonic parachute
inflation research experiment which is
an acronym and it's a spire does that
click NASA this 54-foot so oh so they
they launch this thing up wait so they
launched a test payload up into the
atmosphere and then it fell to earth and
then they open the parachute and it
didn't break which is great because it
has happened before we'll do a test
parachute launch and it just be like
room just shreds yeah cuz if it fails it
fails catastrophic immediately because
that that moment when it opens is the
moment is by far the most stress so the
parachute worked and and and NASA's gone
full speed ahead with the Mars 2020
mission which is very exciting and I
can't wait for there to be two amazing
science labs on the surface of Mars
Caitlin what did we learn today we
learned that even if your aunt wants you
to have a girlfriend you can make your
own choices and we learned that that
Nathan's mom is also maybe a pickle
salesperson oh yeah it goes to the dry
cleaners yeah I don't really know what
that was about
vinegar get stains out yeah we also
learned that when your trash falls on
the ground it is litter no matter how
close it is to the trash can
and we learned that if you are working
at an event where someone is speaking
the speech is for you as much as easy as
it is for anybody Katherine enjoy I hope
you're actually Scottish and I didn't
just make that up yeah we also learned a
little bit about the Scottish government
today a little bit just a very very
small amount and also that they're
apparently they're people in Sweden
named Fanny yes that's the thing this
that was this episode of dear Hank and
John with a guest host Caitlin
Hofmeister thank you very much yeah I'm
glad that you could do it on short
notice but also that you could do it at
all because it's great to have you and
I'm sure John is feeling better by now I
hope sounds it does take a little bit of
time for these episodes to come out but
John feel better yeah this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson our head of community and
communications is Victoria bon giorno
the music that you're hearing is by the
great gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome oh
hey you're still you're still listening
what a champion you are it must be like
a big fan of podcast sir at least this
podcast maybe you even want to watch
this podcast happened live along with a
bunch of other podcasts like lore my
brother my brother and me and Harry
Potter and the sacred texts so many
others besides those I just don't want
to take your time telling you all about
them maybe you want to see some weird
one-off podcast that no one will ever be
able to see again any other way or have
discussions about the podcasting
industry and learn about how people make
it work in work to inspire themselves
and other people oh yeah that sounds
like fun
also this is like maybe your last chance
to get tickets for pod con which is
happening December 9th and 10th in
Seattle it's a conference for people who
love podcasting and podcasts you can
find out more about it at pod con calm
thank you for supporting to your Hank
and John and I hope to see you there